welcome back to cbs this morning
every year at christmas some of the most
popular toys sell
out leaving kids and even some grown-ups
without that special gift they were
hoping for and if this year wasn't bad
enough
toy and game shortages are even more
extreme than usual
some people are reselling them for
double the price
our consumer investigative correspondent
anna warner looks at how this shipping
backlog
is leaving shoppers in a lurch
just how far will someone go to find a
playstation 5 video gaming console
ask mom christina dejesus of tampa who
wants one for her eight-year-old son
here i go on a mission i've tried going
to the stores i've waited in long lines
and it's just been it's impossible
she even set up a twitter account to
track announcements of new online sales
but rushing to buy one as soon as i
clicked on it it was sold out already i
don't even know how that's possible both
the playstation
5 and xbox series x are in high demand
along with many other holiday toys
compounding the problem
shipping delays many toys are likely
sitting in containers on ships like
these
sent from china and waiting up to two
days to be unloaded at the overflowing
port of los angeles
right now we're in a triage situation
jean soroka is the port's executive
director
the manufacturers overseas all the way
here to the port
everyone's backed up can't keep up with
the orders they're producing as much as
they can
on the asia side the ships can only take
so much cargo
86 of the world's toys are made in china
industry expert richard gottlieb
consults for toy companies around the
globe
we've had been having trouble last few
months getting
containers to put the toys in and ship
them from
china and that is largely due to the
fact that
there was a sudden surge in demand for
for toys and other consumer products
so there was a lot of catching up to do
and when you put all that together it's
an imperfect storm it's a storm that may
even have snared
a toddler coco melon musical bedtime jj
doll
or at least a toddler doll the jj doll
based on a character in this coco melon
cartoon good morning
the series has 100 million followers on
youtube and its new doll is selling out
they love these rebecca ray of oklahoma
wanted one for her one-year-old grandson
and every time i found one online for my
grandson it was always sold out
ray scoured sales in the internet and
wound up buying eight
of the hard to locate dolls paying 40
dollars a piece
double the list price of 1999 for most
of them
she now plans to keep two for her
grandkids and the six others
she's giving them away for free to
strangers
you've kind of become santa claus here
yes and no we do it every year
the family taught their children it
truly was better to give than to receive
even jj dolls we got them and
just to give back basically to give them
to other people
we had nine kids so we knew what it was
like to not be able to give them the
things that they wanted or to have to
fight to get something that they did
want
in fact what seven-year-old kayson
wanted this year was a playstation 5
but he says he'll wait until january so
his mom can afford to give away the
dolls
i think they should get their gifts way
before me
i want to give whatever i can to them
why are you okay
with giving away gifts when you're gonna
have to wait
for your gift until probably after
christmas because instead of me
smiling i want to see them smile
well one person who received one of
those dolls for free from the raise
says she plans to pay it forward by
buying gifts for the elderly in nursing
homes
who can't see their families she also
said that she thinks that kayson's going
to do great things in the future in his
life jerica
oh i think so without a doubt anna and
thank goodness we still do have santa to
make
those things happen in case there are
shipping delays
right just in case for sure
thanks anna i remember wanting a coleco
electric electronic quarterback what a
great 1978 shortage
of coleco football games okay who's
large in my life
teddy ruxpin for me all right i wanted a
power wheel okay
my sister got one it's an audi it's like
a card i thought it was cool at nine or
ten but it's really for like five and
six-year-olds
i was really a little annoyed when i um
when santa got that before my sister
instead of me
you know more than a half million people
actually work at the port of los
angeles so if they can't get this going
oh i know
oh man and my dad didn't want me to have
any action figures because he thought
they were dolls
and i was like dad they're action
figures action figures
we'll get that for you